would you give up your whole life if you
got a letter from Hogwarts you can never
see your parents again your friends your
animals you have to go to Hogwarts would
you give up everything no question
sayara family I'll never see you again
okay side question what if it wasn't
Hogwarts it was one of the other schools
like the all girl school like your
backup school yeah your backup choice
still yes you would Sophia you have one
life on this Earth and you have the
option to be a wizard with a wand and
live in a mythical land yeah no taxes
that's no 9 to5 no real world
responsibilities about the classes that
you get to take like dark arts class
quiddit that's your
PE you start laughing last night cuz
we're talking about all the classes that
we could possibly take at Hogwarts and
then we said what if they gave us our
schedule back it's like dark arts
quiddit training then it's like Spanish
101 damn it like wait
econ biology